um
i i think what ian was trying to say is
that
when i tell you this next story
instead of saying joe biden mocked for
shaking hands with thin air after speech
i should go so there he was
but in turn to his right
in his mind the hallucination of a
strong man reaching out to shake his
hand
i didn't reached
but there was nothing
but the best part of this the stars and
stripes is on top of all of that
happening
the band's playing it oh yeah yeah so so
joe biden claims that he uh was a
professor at what you pen yeah
he never even taught one class there
yo is is like
what if the conspiracy theory you know
the by dan conspiracy theory have you
heard this
so it's that there's it's he's not
actually joe biden he's a replacement
called by dan and like the real story is
that joe biden got plastic surgery and
look kind of different but people
compare joe biden before and joe biden
now and it's like it is creepy it is but
he got he's older and he got plastic
surgery that's what it looks like but so
there's the conspiracy theorists are
like he's by dan not by den that's what
they call him or whatever but uh
maybe he's like he was this guy was a
professor at u-pen and now he's old and
doesn't realize he's not or whatever or
who's ridiculous
no but all seriousness
joe biden tried to shake hands with thin
air i genuinely think he may have been
hallucinating i i really do mean it um
i'm wondering if or my question is how
could he possibly
mistake himself as a professor at
university
yeah you were explaining this brett like
he was uh he actually was got an
honorary degree yes so he you penn paid
him and he this is not the first time
that he's claimed this because i was
reading a daily car date i was reading a
daily caller article about it that was
that came out in 2019. and in 2019 he
had already been proclaiming that he was
a full professor but what happened was
that you penn paid him a little over
seven hundred thousand dollars to be
like it was like a benjamin franklin
honorary professor or something like
that and basically all he had to do was
show up around the campus be sort of a
figurehead wander around i don't know
where that money went who knows what he
did with it maybe hunter has it we'll
see but
but he's great at wandering around
exactly i mean he's fantastic at it
maybe that's all he thinks that
professors do but he he was paid by the
university but he was far from being any
kind of professor but in his mind he has
a history of lying like uh he's a
plagiarist in 88 i brought that up
before he ran for the president when he
rubs his nose or the eyebrow you got you
know he's like just tell yeah oh okay if
you watch his videos yeah you're a biden
whisperer i see i spend a lot of time
watching his videos on the internet as
an actor i do the same thing you used to
study people and watch them move well
how many videos do we need
of joe biden wandering around not
knowing where he's going not knowing
what he's talking about is it a mockery
like at what point is it is it like
how many people have been talking about
it since before
even like his mind is not going to hold
up
it feels like a mockery no like he's
mocking us well i mean like the whole
thing it kind of feels like
a mockery of the you think i'm broken
and he acts like it like as as the the
archetypal figurehead of the united
states at the end of our life span
there's this mockery this guy that can't
even keep a sentence together i mean i'm
talking metaphorically like i mean
obviously there's probably a more
nuanced explanation to it i think and
when i say sick i just mean that it
seems like his mind has been clouded or
he's getting old he's losing like i
don't know if it's all high onset
dementia whatever but a sick society
will create a sick leader and i'm not
sickness is a vague word but this is an
example of like people voting for
something they hate because they hate
something else more uh
you do not a healthy society puts the
smartest and the best in power i don't
understand this is this is just
arrangement
well they hated donald trump
and they were willing to take
the craziest
laziest out of his mindiest
so that's what we get i don't think joe
biden will be able to run in 2024
absolutely not i mean ben was saying
that they're going to strap him to a
gurney but i'm like come on
yeah i guess but even that's not going
to work maybe he'll run and then try and
make somebody else look good you know
what his slogan would be
2009 to shove it to pressure
or next no resin yeah and um uh batacaf
here here's a new one remember when he
said the united states can be summed up
in one word and he said i'm sorry for
minimalia
or something like that i didn't i didn't
my favorite is just we're back
we're back we're back that's only i
think you can actually say coherently is
we're back
oh he could say come on man that's it
yeah look at that going to get real
he's good at saying putin caused
inflation
or go get him that was the end of his uh
state of the union his catch phrase it's
not my fault it's putin's fault it's not
my fault everything yeah he like slips
on a banana peel oh putin
do what did you guys see that he got
shot on by a bird yes yeah and he
everybody was like always going to blame
well
he made a video earlier i think
analyzing it what'd you come up with so
snope says he wasn't pooped on it was
actually corn or a said it was a corn by
product
oh my gosh oh it was a literal corn pop
he was standing next to a big pile of
corn
at an ethanol plant where they take corn
it turned into ethanol and so they said
it clearly was corn and when they show
in slow motion you can see it hits him
and it does break apart like
bits and not goop
however here's the issue
the new york post said it was bird poop
snopes and many other outside it was
corn and i'm like no one actually knows
none of you can prove it the white house
claims it was corn you don't know that
so here's what i say
the splatter on his lapel
the corn retains it's it's it's it's it
looks like if it was corn and it might
be it's in a viscous matter of some sort
because
if powdered corn ball hit you the whole
thing would break apart
if there was a wet ball with corn in it
it would hit you
and then corn bits would splatter down
but it would retain its splatter shape
because there's a viscous material
holding it together
i say it's possible that there was a
bird in there that ate a bunch of the
corn and then pooped it out on him and
it was in its poop or the simple answer
is why are fact checkers claiming they
know what it is when they don't
by all means say we don't know if it was
bird poop i'm fine with that something
fell on him sure but then they were like
fact check biden wasn't pooped on i'm
like
you didn't fact-check that's your
opinion yeah because you could like zoom
in on the photo and it's like it doesn't
look like typical bird poop it's not
like white it has i mean it does now
that you said the point i hadn't seen
that it does kind of look more like that
i mean i got pooped on here the other
day straight eyebrows but they they
pulled it it does not look like that
they called it
byproduct because they couldn't even say
it was corn a corn by-product it was
like partially digested corn i imagine
that birds can't digest it fully or
something or they ate too much like that
giant that giant mound a bird could have
just eaten until i got sick and barfed
on them from maybe yeah or or maybe it
was a mother bird carrying food around
to bring back to the babies in the nest
oh yeah
you know
i had a moment i was walking up to the
front door of the daily wire building
and as i'm walking i'm about five feet
from the wall in the door and i hear up
like a splatter and i look and i see a
little white splotch and i was like oh
that was close and i look up and there
was a little bird butt right over the
edge it was just it was just really
awesome i could see like there's a
little bird standing there and his butt
hanging over i'm like he just took a
dump what animals have you guys been
crapped on
i'll go first if you want well bird last
week well no it was like two weeks ago i
did a hit on ben's show and i was
walking back and it was right there and
i was like
living large yeah i took the birds
the snake was interesting because it was
like this white stuff just came out of
the bottom of it on the knee it's kind
of neat oh uh human babies oh yeah yeah
yeah so i get pooped on often and and
rabbits
oh yeah which actually isn't i mean they
they're relentless [ __ ] but i mean
like it's it's just these little things
yeah but you know they they also eat
their own poop yeah they do they don't
they don't want to say their own babies
they don't really
they don't really eat their own poop
what they're eating is when the rabbits
eat plant matter it has to go through
their system more than once so some
sometimes poop comes out and sometimes
it looks like poop but it's actually
just partially digested plant matter
they turn around and eat it again
yeah rabbits people got to understand
rabbits are not pets nope that's crazy
to me that people like well they freaked
me out too yeah they're they're white
ones with the red eyes
albino are they considered albino i
don't know
they're they're delicate they have
delicate uh
systems
people you can't really bathe them like
they're not great pets like people get
them for their kids chew everything but
they're they're
high maintenance
get them a guinea pig yeah well these
rabbits attack our feet they're not
smart you know like i mean they're
they're fun actually but like we'll like
it'll be dark and i'm walking through
the house and they'll just run straight
from my feet not realizing like i could
crush you dude on accident what do they
think it is not that you know but
they're super playful like if if i run
away they'll run after me
you know and my kids love just running
across the house and do you
get them fixed
no we just have two boys oh okay um but
they still hump each other like crazy
really yeah we funny to watch i had some
rabbits and you know we we understood
you know they're warning they
good rabbit you know dealers or pet
shops will will explain to you like how
you take care of the rabbits so when i
was in miami we actually had a whole
room with just two rabbits in it it
wasn't that big of a room but it was
like it's a decently sized room we just
the rabbits had the room to themselves
they poop everywhere and we'd feed them
and then we clean and stuff but they
started getting into it because it was a
boy and a girl and so it didn't really
work out because you know rabbits are
and the girl when she didn't want it she
would jump like eight feet in the air
because we put up a big barrier so the
room was like a sun room it was like
it was a room but the door was just
always open so we put a big thing in
front of it and she would just
straight over it and one day i go in
there and she's gone we find her
upstairs hiding because the dude rabbit
was like you know
he was he was oppressing her wow
yeah nice way of saying it would i would
i yeah what i like about it is like
there's a lot of fertilizer and i've
gotten seriously into the importance of
topsoil topsoil and just
the microbes in the soil and there's
like farmers around tennessee down in
summertown that are like within six
years gonna have like several feet of
topsoil on their farm like really doing
it incredibly so but they have like
guineas water buffalo different cows
like tons of different animals and
they're doing it right so that's why i
don't mind seeing the the bunny crap
everywhere i just go around speaking of
crap yeah you know what this is in the
blind post biden getting pooped on thing
makes me think of the bernie sanders
when the bird landed on his podium oh
yeah that was that it was like a magical
moment people yeah and then here's the
other magical moment yeah yeah well so
we have uh uh you guys probably know it
chicken city oh yeah and those things
poop
oh my gosh
everywhere so what i love about them is
that they're smart enough not to drink
poop water but they're not smart enough
not to poop in their water so it's like
you hand them water they'll drink it
they'll turn around just take a dump
right in it and look at it and go like i
drinking that it's like well you did it
dude but uh when you go into the chicken
coop i always tell people because when
people come over they'll be like oh can
i come check them out i'll be yeah but
your feet are going to be covered caked
in just chicken crap
and they're like oh you wash them off
afterwards so you can just not go in
there and you know chickens they poop is
it safe enough to put plastic bags on
your feet i was just thinking about
those painters those painter ones
yeah just go with it just be one
of them yeah when i go home to my
family's farm it's like i know for a
fact that it's like i'm not coming out
on skates it must be good for your biome
to be like was it joey salatin i think
is his name is it uh joel salatin
yeah it's all about getting in there
with the pig feces and like it how it
enhances your biome and your immune
system i think i'm healthier because i
was you know playing in the dirt as well
yeah for sure because i wasn't a purell
kid
purell kid yeah that actually things are
scary help with allergies early exposure
helps with allergies it's you just got
to be careful with like the the parasite
cycles but actually having a diversity
of animals they'll eat each other's crap
and break the parasite cycles as well
that's weird yep if you have them
roaming around the same ground they'll
break the parasite cycles
and also keeping quail
is really incredible because they don't
make a ton of noise their eggs are
really dense uh you know nutrient dense
and um yeah they don't make much noise
so you can be in kind of like an urban
environment and you won't have that
noise all the time i think i need some
quails
chickens are noisy yeah yeah man we got
roberto and then we got roberto junior
yeah the kid and they just yell non-stop
the ladies are cool no no no no no no no
i think the ladies are actually worse
really so yeah the roosters are loud but
the girls just complain all day they're
not really complaining they complain to
each other they're actually really happy
but they go around and they go like bark
bark
yeah and you know like i'll hear the
cons so it's one thing to hear a
cockadoodle do once in a while or the
crowing it's another thing when for like
30 minutes you're having
what is are they laying an egg when they
do that so typically it's probably more
than one chicken and they're doing the
egg song what is that they they they lay
an egg and then they sing oh wow
you guys ever had pink cheeks no i would
love to have you well i will so my my
mother's birthday was in february and
her birthday present for me was a pet
pig but it's out there but yeah i have
pig what teacup pig no she's no she's
going to be full size her name's nora
but i got her she was like two months
old i was here already i had her
delivered to my mom had it all set up
and i don't know how big she is now her
name's nora that animal
i mean so loud you if she does not want
to be touched she's super sweet and she
like comes when you call her she's like
a dog but if you touch her in a weird
way i mean it's like squishy all hell i
mean the loudest thing on the farm by
like a long thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you